we have lived through an experience of
consolidation in the internet industries
they are not industries they were before
they are controlled by fewer and fewer
players and I think they have to be
watched very carefully so the world that
we have now is not a world in which big
companies will continue to dominate
everything it's a very dynamic world and
places like MySpace are no place today
precisely because they couldn't keep up
with the competition so much of what
Richard Epstein wants to happen so much
of this idea of churn of new companies
coming in industry of new voices being
heard is a result of some kind of outer
limit and you may not do this we are in
the situation in which we have a tech
boom not a tech bust and we want to be
extremely opposed than any particular
kinds of proposals that will upset the
applecart in order to secure a series of
benefits which we will regret should we
ever have them again the resolution
reads antitrust should take the
initiative to control the size of the
big tech companies taking the
affirmative Tim Wu Tim please come to
the stage taking the negative Richard
Epstein Richard please come to the stage
Jana please close the voting and the
affirmative goes first that's Tim wolf
for 15 minutes Tim take it away what
yeah look put it put it there and then
as you know your timer will be right in
front flashing five and two minute signs
all right let me begin by saying that
was the least relaxing comedy routine
I've heard in a while but
I'll try and make you feel better so as
I see it we are on the tail end of a
20-year experiment in which we have
allowed an unprecedented and in many
ways unamerican abandonment of the
principles of competition and the ideals
of a decentralized economy and it is my
proposition today that we need to begin
to reverse those policies to begin to
have greater control in the interests of
competition in the interests of free
markets over over consolidation of of
this economy and I believe that that
approach should begin with big tech
which is a poster child the most visible
form of monopolies in most of our lives
and also an industry and a series of
companies which have developed a
dangerous level of power over over not
only the economy but also politics in
our country over even our daily lives
and the accumulation of data and private
information it is my proposition that it
is the American tradition and an
important role in the economy to have
some controls over monopoly even if you
believe in a free market the abandonment
of even the most minimal controls has
led us to a situation that is
unacceptable and I want to give four
reasons for that in the time that I have
remaining for it to me so the first is
an argument from antitrust in general
which is the argument that monopolies
simply take too much away from the
economy and are inefficient so these are
the economic arguments I want to point
out to you that in the last 20 years in
a period which we've allowed
unprecedented consolidations of so many
American industries we've been left with
a country where Americans pay pay more
for for so many basic items whether it's
broadband whether it's our cell phone
plans whether it's airplane tickets
HealthCare Pharmaceuticals so across
the board across industries the
abandonment or the weakening of
antitrust has had a the predictable
effect of allowing oligopolies or
monopolies to arise and across
industries and give people less for more
money I think many of us have
experienced this firsthand if you you
know have at any interactions with the
healthcare system if you feel that the
airline industry with just three majors
might have seemed of increased prices
increase its fees on everything
reduce your seat sizes you know that's
sort of the the poster child allowing
consolidation of the airline industry of
what the rest of the economy has looked
like look beginning look like including
a big tech and I want to add to it of
that across the line weakening of
antitrust weakening of the basic idea
that monopolization is is illegal that
mergers of competitors should not be
allowed has also contributed to that the
problem of inequality which you know
regardless sure across this political
spectrum is is become a looming issue of
our time and that is for a number of
reasons I'd be happy to discuss in
questions but the the basic economic
principle is that if you allow excessive
corporate consolidation if you will it
leads predictably to higher corporate
profits which are generally returned to
shareholders and in terms of either
stock buybacks or dividends or other
methods which tends to accelerate the
tendency of a smaller number of citizens
to have more money than the rest and
this I is I'll pick up in the political
side of the debate has exacerbated many
of the political contentions the
division of the United States a sense
that the the coasts of the country are
in some ways in a different position in
the center of the country these are all
trends that are exacerbated I don't say
exclusively cause but exacerbated by the
weakening of antitrust enforcement the
abandonment of the curbs on monopolies
so the second reason I want to focus on
which is
to the tech monopolies is the problem
that tech monopolies like other
monopolist simply take too much from the
rest of the economy
now Richard may argue in his time and I
suspect he will that the the good thing
about the tech monopolies is that they
have provided new conveniences and and
services to consumers and I concede that
I don't deny that these are good
companies I think that they are you know
I don't think these are so the stag
stagnant backwaters or anything like
that but the problem in allowance of
tech monopoly is the degree to which it
starts to seize income sees revenue sees
opportunity from the rest of the economy
people who are at all to take one
example you know what is the problem
with Amazon
the problem with Amazon isn't that it's
bad for consumers the problem for Amazon
is the the effect it has on other parts
of the economy like suppliers and where
its buying power results in it having
the ability to Sookie's squeezed
suppliers across the economy and make it
very difficult for them to make a profit
now Amazon this point is has not even
reached its full extent but if you
imagine a future where Amazon is the
more or less exclusive way of doing
business if it has no real competitors
in the retail sector it's not hard to
see that's a very difficult economy to
make money in if you're anyone other
than tech or other than Amazon so I
think this the the main problem when you
focus on a company like Amazon which in
some ways is very appealing and I will
concede those points is the effects on
the rest of economy and this squeeze of
opportunity and profits the third point
I wish to raise in a defense of this
proposition is the fact that antitrust
actually has a strong and good track
record when it comes the problem of
tackling tech man Appa Lee now I don't
want to have an you know a lengthy
lecture on the history of the antitrust
laws but I want to talk about three
times that the government has taken on
tech monopolies in the past
and has produced good results for the US
economy so in the 1970s and 1980s the
Giants of the day where IBM in AT&T and
at a time when the United States was
facing increased competition from Japan
not unlike the competition we face now
from China where the idea was that we
should be supporting our national
champions we should be helping out AT&T
and IBM the approach of the US
government was very different
it broke from the approach that the
Japanese were taking which was not
unlike China's to support their their
monopolies to to give them everything
they wanted to make sure they were not
subject to excessive competitive
pressure and instead the US government
took aim at IBM and in AT&T and
attempted to break up both of these
firms at the time many people said this
was a terrible idea at a time with
rehearsal many of the arguments people
say people said you know everyone loves
the bail system they rely on it
IBM there's a beloved American innovator
no one could be better these are the
arguments I think that we'll hear today
about how great and thoughtful efficient
these firms were nonetheless the US
government took their case they broke
AT&T up into eight different firms and
they nearly broke up IBM but certainly
chasing around for 13 years and forced
it to separate software from hardware
the consequences of those cases as I
said people the times would be a
terrible idea but if you look at the
companies and the economic activity that
was opened up by the cases against the
great monopolies they actually formed
much of today's economy in the chase
against IBM or the pressure on IBM it it
it it opened the software industry and
gave rise to companies you know first
small ones but later companies like
Microsoft companies that would later
grow into the monopolists themselves in
the pressure put on IBM to to
make sure it didn't excessively dominate
the the PC space out came companies like
IBM Intel absent the old printer maker
in other words these campaigns against
the computer monopolist made it obvious
in retrospect that a lot was being held
back and I think if the government does
conduct campaigns that is actually
currently involved in against Facebook
Google Amazon it will begin to give
space to the entrepreneurs that have
always been the backbone of growth of
the US economy and I think that if we
surrender and we say well we shouldn't
do anything you know we shouldn't have
we should take we should worship our
great tech companies we should trust
them to take us the future that we're
going to look back at some period and
wonder you know those companies that
seem so great five or ten years ago have
begun to stagnate have become more like
General Motors Chrysler Ford you know
companies that grew too big stayed
around too long and ultimately upheld up
the American economy alright I want to
turn to my final reason why I think
that's important too to have scrutiny a
big tech and consider limiting size and
that is a political argument about
centered on the American distrust for
concentrated unaccountable power I think
that we live in a time where we have to
recognize that there is too much
potential in affect exercised power in a
few small tech firms this is a
consequence not only of their
aggregation of data but also by the fact
that a disproportionate amount of speech
a disproportionate amount of what people
see in here goes through just several
small platforms and no matter what your
political persuasion is no matter what
you think of this candidate or that
candidate I think it's important to be
wary of a system so
centered on just a few platforms one
that is has already proven itself
vulnerable to foreign manipulation and
one that is constantly at risk of being
a system with a single point of failure
I think it's much safer time has told us
to have a more decentralized system for
speech to have multiple points of
failure and not to just have one or two
companies and in fact a decision of just
a few people decide what is saleable or
not saleable to decide potentially who
is the advantage in an election I'm
struck by the fact that when you
consider the debate over Facebook's
advertising political advertising how
much is decided how much in effect
everyone assumes the decisions of one
person Mark Zuckerberg will have on the
2020 election and if there's any
principle that is supposed to be the the
principle of democracy it's so you know
one person shall have no kingly
prerogative to decide where political
power should lie I add to that I add to
that finally the problem that monopolies
have always had excessive influence over
the outcomes of the political discourse
and we are in a position where we risk a
future where technically in some sense
for place in many aspects government in
our lives and decide what it means to
live decide the most important
conditions of our lives and decide
things and in that sense I'm at the
question of whether you think we should
have more discipline of the tech
monopolies is in some ways a question of
whether you believe in democracy or not
because we have in some ways aggregated
a lot of the most important public
decisions - a series of smaller
companies I think for the principles of
democracy alone that trend must be
resisted even if we occasionally like to
order things that arrive in one day
thank you very much and
[Applause]
Richard Epstein for the negative you
take the podium Richard yeah I know you
can't not to say that all rights for
having a bull under these circumstances
every Minister Richard it's a very great
pleasure to be here and and let me see
if I can state the opposite side of the
position
Tim began with a statement that just
think of what the antitrust laws has
been like in the last 20 years and how
much things have changed well start
going back to say 2020 and you ask
yourself who was not around all the
companies that he now wants to regulate
were either much smaller or non-existent
at that particular point in time and all
of them have generally grown at the same
time if you start looking at the
positions with respect to the antitrust
laws it's not as though they've taken an
abnegation on the way in which
monopolies ought to be controlled just
yesterday I read a long disposition by
the Deputy Attorney General who
announced that in these particular cases
we are going to continue with the set of
sanctions that we imposed upon a cartel
formation by giving leniency for the
first person to confess so that we can
throw everybody else in jail and then
we'll work out other kinds of an
arrangements there's absolutely no sign
whatsoever across either the Clinton or
the present administration or any
administration in between that the case
against cartels has not been made if you
look at the merger market the same kind
of guidelines that have always been used
before now being used again and
basically what happens is if you're
trying to go 3 to 2 or 2 to 1 you can't
do that if you're trying to go 5 to 4
and you check the analysis generally
speaking a word which Tim did not
mention but which needs to be mentioned
is that the efficiencies associated with
some of these unions are greater than
any restrictive prices they could get
and so the case that's on the basically
on the cutting edge is the four-to-three
merger and that seems to me also to be a
situation which is sound on antitrust
law then if you start looking at the way
in which various companies start to work
there's been a very established offering
for a long time which says that if you
in fact are able to achieve your
particular growth from eternal expansion
through acumen or through good luck this
is not an ant
trust the violation it isn't effect
something which says that the reason you
got where you got is not because you
have an operator where none exist that
you created opportunities for other
individuals which were never available
to you before and so as I start to look
at the antitrust laws that's come down
there has been a pretty strong Democrat
and Republican consensus with respect to
these particular positions and the
question is why would anybody want to
change something given the fact that if
you look at the European market which
has a rather different antitrust laws
the number of new corporations of any
consequence the size that it's been able
to create is exactly zero and they spend
most of their time trying to figure out
how they could wreck American companies
because they have a kind of
international and be associated with the
operation of the system so that's the
first point then when you start coming
to the question is there anything
specific about tech markets or may turns
out that the first thing you have to do
is to remember what the question was
and the question was do we want to limit
the size of these companies the question
was not whether or not we ought to give
all of these companies a free pass and
the way in which we start to deal with
these particular issues so I'm happy to
report right now I'm working on a case
and which is not on the Google Sun it's
on the other side of this particular
circumstances and it's an antitrust
lawyer over the past years I've been a
plank to Sky and I've been a defendants
Khan because it seems to me that the
system once you get it right is
something which has a certain amount of
sense and balance associated with its
operation so if the question is whether
you want to break up these companies the
question that you have to then ask is a
simple one do you think that there's
some other kind of remedy that you can
do with respect to the practices that
these companies undertake which would
solve the monopoly problem without
creating the breakup problem now why is
it you want to do this breaking up as
they like to say is very very hard to do
particularly if you are in a network
kind of industry if you break up the
network then people from one side of the
industry cannot get contact the people
on the other side of the industry unless
what you do is you create a series of
interconnection agreements which is we
know from the telephone industry turn
out to be extremely difficult to execute
and indeed when Tim mentioned
they broke up the situation with respect
to AT&T in 1982 it wasn't because the
antitrust laws were inadequate it's
because we had this elaborate system of
regulation by the FCC which shielded it
from the antitrust laws and then they
broke it up it is worth mentioning
however when they broke it up they
didn't know how to break it up and so
what happened is the consolidation that
took place afterwards showed the folly
of the system that had been created
which having local exchange carriers on
the one side and AT&T is a long lines
carrying on the other side it turned out
that the much more efficient system was
companies vertically integrated on the
one hand coupled with that new arrival
which they never took into account in
1982 what are we supposed to do with the
cell phone when it comes along and by
the time you get to 2005 there are more
cell phones than they turned out there
were landlines and the whole stuff that
Harold Greene was doing essentially
turned out to be quite farcical because
he put such inhibitions with respect to
innovation that took place that the
general view was that he held back
progress in that particular industry of
my several years are you looking at IBM
and it's the same kind of story it
basically is a prelude to a case that
Tim did not mention which is the
Qualcomm case on which I work and AT&T
was whether the IBM case was brought the
day before the Johnson administration
went out of power just as the Qualcomm
case was brought by the Obama
administration three days before it went
out of power and is this thing going to
do any good well what was the theory
that you had against IBM it was very
difficult to talk about it slowed things
up and then when Bill backs to the very
person who decided to prosecute the AT&T
case came along he dismissed with
prejudice the IBM case saying that it
was meritless and in fact in the interim
what did it do to IBM it certainly
slowed its kind of innovation up because
you now know every time you are going to
engage in a new product or a new price
somebody's gonna come and look at you
and say uh-huh
you're now engaged in a form of monopoly
what did they do is they gave
opportunities for many other companies
to get into business by selling to them
stuff which they could then use and it
turns out if you look at companies like
Microsoft and Apple later on it turns
out many of these companies actually had
sensible relationships with IBM
before they spun off and did their own
thing if you recall Bill Gates who had
an opportunity to buy back his operating
system because I believe it was IBM
decided that Justin wanted in a rare
display of commercial acumen by a large
company what you have to understand is
that these big guys in some cases have
huge advantages but in some cases
they're at an enormous disadvantage if
you want to do a start-up you cannot do
it being a little Bank inside a big bank
you have to be an independent company or
otherwise you cannot align the
incentives your inventive what's going
on so the world that we have now is not
a world in which big companies will
continue to dominate everything it's a
very dynamic world and places like
MySpace and no place today precisely
because they couldn't keep up with the
competition
it wasn't the antitrust law that spelled
the end of the AOL situation remember it
was going to take over Time Warner and
by the time it was done it was history
and Time Warner had to ditch it these
are amazingly dynamic markets and the
fact that you have dominant players
today and dominant players ten years ago
and dominant players ten years from now
doesn't mean that you're going to have
the same dominant players at all these
times the churn is every bit as
important as the current consideration
and every current so-called monopolist
knows that there is a sword of Damocles
hanging over their heads which will say
if we make a misstep it will be on a
last step and somebody else will then
come along under these circumstances and
take all the particular situations that
we have and move them to the other side
so then how is it when you want to do
this thing do you start to think about
the way in which these industries ought
to be regulated and the first thing that
you start to do is you say well they're
not all the same kinds of industries and
they all may need very different kinds
of treatments and you have to be careful
that you've gotten the right treatment
so what are you gonna do with respect
the Amazon whose major sign is reliable
delivery on the one hand at low prices
on the other a first thing you do is
remember they don't win in every market
in which standard there are certain
cases and which smaller more adept
players are much better and when you're
trying to look at this particular stuff
what you have to remember is it's not
the global size that determines
competitive straw
a large company like Amazon can face
competition in each local market by two
or three small people who are much more
adept in their own space than Amazon can
be so that it's not a case of
essentially the big guy having no
competition it's not a case of the big
guy having competition by one or two
other companies it's a case of a big guy
having lots of competition from lots of
companies in lots of different markets
and it has a disadvantage that it has to
form national policy when they're trying
to figure out how it is that they deal
with local situation so what should we
do in Amazon buy away with respect to
their goods and don't read the
Washington Post and it seems to me that
you will come up when somebody laughs at
least I you will come up with something
that looks to be the same thing if you
look at the situation with respect to
Microsoft they wanted to put all sorts
of duties on it so that they could not
introduce products that would have
anti-competitive edges and they had to
establish the compatibility with
services from other people and IBM took
a terrible advantage of this situation
by saying you have to examine protocols
with hundreds after hundreds of
different products that we're gonna put
out it's gonna cost you a fortune and
most of these things that were asking
you to examine for this kind of stuff
turn out to be stuff that we're never
going to use um if you continue down
this particular line and take the recent
Qualcomm situation and one of the worst
judgments ever entered into in the
history of antitrust law
you take America's major 5g company and
you want to subject to world revision of
the rates being done in a San Jose Court
they're telling them how they ought to
follow and deal with their products when
they're selling them in Korea or in
Japan or other places which have in fact
their own antitrust law this is
absolutely crazy and then it turns out
that when they start to go somewhat
further what you say in the fact is that
the antitrust law now gives you a duty
to compete not only to compete with your
competitors but to supply them at below
market prices are your particular
technology so that they compete with you
and the Trinko doctrine which was one
that was established in about 2004 makes
it very clear that your antitrust
obligation is not to support your
competitors but to try and run your own
business in a perfectly coherent in
general way so if you start to look at
the way in which the
medial structure comes out in these
particular cases where there has been
found to be an antitrust violation what
you typically discover is that the
remedy in many of these cases turns out
to be far worse than the disease and it
turns out that the best way in which to
deal with this stuff is in fact to
encourage new entry by removing whatever
barriers to entry it turns out to be now
what are these barriers to entry well
sometimes it's kind of funny let me just
mention to you two things one is
Jonathan Barnett has an excellent new
book and what she says is the key
barrier to entry in many of the tech
industries is a weak not a too strong
patent law and why is that because the
companies that are entering the small
companies they do not have an elaborate
industrial structure either they get
patent protection and they get nothing
but if you're an Intel or you're some
large company you can protect yourself
by contracting by trade secrets and
other devices and so you get the paradox
that it's all the big and established
companies that are opposed to strong
patent connection and all the small
companies which turn out to be in favor
of it so if you're trying to figure out
what it is that's going on in these
cases when you're figuring out the ways
in which these things are gonna take
place it turns out that it's much more
difficult to do that than Timur said
then there's also the problem what
counts as a barrier to entry there's a
danger of many kinds of shall we say
effective cases as well as some real
cases so effective cases a recent
suggestion that the reason we find that
facebook has a barrier to entry is that
it lolled people in with the promisee of
strong privacy protection then change
the rules and by that time it had a
monopoly position that's the kind of
crazy theory that nobody should give
credit to if you don't like the privacy
policies you can ask Facebook to amend
them and they've done it multiple times
or you can decide to take your business
elsewhere and a company like snapchat
not that I use any of these particular
services turns out to be getting much
greater shares than you have so you have
to be very careful when people simply
allege that there's abuse to look at it
closely on the other hand if you're a
company like Google and you're running a
network and what you do is you make it
impossible by removing an old technology
when one of your competitors to sell
their stuff that's a very
serious operation it's not straight an
antitrust case it's also a case that has
to do my landlords with your competitive
obligations your good-faith services and
so forth
now last what Tim mentioned was that we
have to worry about the internet in the
control of ideas and he made a segments
of the sort which Mark Zuckerberg should
not have that much influence articulate
though he may be well I run three
podcasts today not a day a week on
average and basically none of them goes
through Facebook although they can
transport it what happens is the rise of
the Internet has meant that little guys
insignificant as I turn out to be turned
out to find somebody like the Hoover
Institution wants to put them out there
you could get free access to all places
on the internet and somebody like me
who'd never been heard of under the
great age beforehand where you had large
fixed telephone company can all of a
sudden get a voice and if you start
looking at the number of sites in every
industry that have independent
production capabilities what you're
impressed with is the cacophony of
different voices rather than with the
fact that under these circumstances you
have only one person who could speak at
all why is this because water
essentially always finds its way if it
turns out that one particular path is
blocked you will take another path in
order to get what you think to be the
appropriate way in which you want to
move your particular resources and so
what you do is you get an absolutely
unmatched variety of things that take
place because free entry on the web is
extremely powerful my friend Larry
Lessig actually had one very good idea
which was the creative commons which
allows also small people for credit to
get their stuff out so we are in the
situation in which we have a tech boom
not a tech bust and we ought to be
extremely opposed to any particular
kinds of proposals that will upset the
applecart in order to secure a series of
benefits which we will regret should we
ever have them thank you
[Applause]
yeah good Jim five minutes rebuttal from
Tim who take it away Jim all right
that's all right well abstainers Oh give
me the fun well you know III don't know
you've done me the favor of giving me a
lot to fight at and I want to start with
just starting with your misunderstanding
of the history of these tech industries
if you look at the narrative of the last
thirty years is not a narrative where
the industry sort of naturally took care
of itself it's an industry it's a
narrative of the industry turning to
monopolies and at crucial points
antitrust interventions breaking things
up and rebooting what was becoming and
dangerously consolidate
you know you talked about how we have
all these type of these firms Google
Microsoft all and-and-and you name it
but those are the out shoots of a very
successful attack on Microsoft which was
in a very dangerous position of
controlling the browser and about 2001
now these are very good companies but I
think the system we've had the reason an
American Tech has been the leader of the
world is because we haven't done what
Japan has done we haven't done what
China is about to do which is just stay
away from from the big monopolies let
them dominate the text faces in their
areas never break them up never threaten
them and I suggest we've had a very
successful plan of putting the tech
monopolist to test forcing them to
compete hard not allowing them to build
up artificial barriers of entry and has
completed in an extraordinary way the
companies themselves for the success of
American tech so I think that what
you're actually describing is an
abandoning of what has been an
incredibly successful program now second
of all you suggested that you suggested
that sort of impractical to limit size
or and and turn to the
question of what this debates all about
so first of all the proposition is that
we should limit the future size of tech
companies so what I'm suggesting is that
we not necessarily have to break up
every tech firm but at the very least we
need to stop the big tech monopolies
from buying their most dangerous
competitors that is what Facebook did
and that is the the the the core of the
case against Facebook is that they
bought their most dangerous competitors
in Instagram in whatsapp and have bought
others which people don't know the names
as well because they're not as prominent
and Google has you know for their sake
bought 260 of their competitors or so
many of these were very friendly
acquisitions I don't think the people
minded getting the payoffs but the net
consequence is when you have too many
companies allowed to buy off too many of
their competitors that you end up with
an environment that is overly overly
monopolized overly concentrated and I
think this is a danger to the viability
the future competitiveness of American
tech this I think you and I both agree
that what has been the success of
American tech is churned the question is
whether that happens naturally or
whether government by putting scrutiny
on anti-competitive practices on
preventing companies from building up
barriers to entry of giving
entrepreneurs their shot of making the
tech economy a place of opportunity as
opposed to a place where monopolies can
do whatever they want whether that is
what leads us finally to churn a minute
on you know this sort of question a
political danger I along with you agree
that the Internet has allowed a lot of
voices obviously to get out there in a
way that was challenging but that is a
view that is I would say threatened by
the domination of just a few platforms
as it stands if you think about the you
know speech codes or the the speech
codes and and the controls of the main
tech platforms they are deciding what
speeches on the internet and I think
that should be a decentralized set of
questions and I want to end by something
once that kind of gives me a sense of
why I think antitrust is an important
player and why
I think there should always be a public
role in deciding what happens in the
private tech industries
once I had a opportunity to talk to Bill
Gates and I slowly moved the topic to
antitrust supposing pretending
suggesting I was a historian more than a
antitrust advocate and he said something
very interesting which I I just want to
close on you know he said II didn't
really like the case and he said all
these sort of things but he said you
know I'd had a lot of things go my way I
sort of deserve my comeuppance and it
did get me into philanthropy about seven
years sooner so I want to suggest there
is this this positive role in control of
any form of power including private
power and including the power of the
tech industries Thanks five nature viral
from by Richard I think we have to be
extremely careful to figure out what it
is that is and is not a barrier to entry
what is and is not something that rather
hopes there is much too much of a danger
now to put attention with respect to the
antitrust law although that's the only
operative force that exists so respect
to new entry I've already mentioned to
you the importance of the patent system
it's also absolutely critical that you
don't have something like the Fair Labor
Standards Act interfere with the churn
and the competition of new companies
when they start to take over it's also
clear that the rules that exist in the
securities industry which make it
progressively difficult for companies to
start to go public has led to a system
where some of these companies are going
to be a crime the second thing I think
you have to do is it's extremely
difficult when you start looking at
these merges to realize whether or not
these are efficiency gains that you're
watching a monopoly practice it you know
you're a company called googling to take
over a company called ways it's got 12
employees it's got revenues of
absolutely nothing and what you have
here is an incredible synergy that can
take place when somebody's got a Matt
connection which is second to none and
somebody else has got a technology that
can be put to use and so the question
you then have to ask is whether or not
want these two people to go separately
at which point the synergies are going
to have to come in some other way and it
could delay these things from happening
to begin with the third thing I think
that one has to remember on this stuff
is if you have several large companies
that are always in the market but buying
small companies or can go public this is
going to be a strong inducement for
people to start to create new companies
that are going to start to take over so
if you start looking at the Obama era it
turns out that anything that looked like
technical innovation was something that
they built with presumptive suspicions
the moment he's out of office and you
then start to look at the number of
startups you see an absolute u-turn
taking place on this thing because it's
generally thought that the Trump
administration was sufficiently
incompetent to sufficiently indifferent
that it wasn't going to wreck the way in
which these companies started to operate
and this has nothing whatsoever to do
with the antitrust law it has to do it
the question as to whether or not when
you start don't do one of these
particular businesses you're gonna be
able to find out having done this
particular business that you're going to
be able to obtain to some extent of some
kind of a decent turn with respect to
the way in which it goes the second
point is when you're dealing with the
antitrust laws this is not a matter of
aspiration this is a matter of technique
and it turns out as I mentioned earlier
it's not a question as to whether you
think there is or is just a violation
and so forth the question is what's the
kind of remedies that you want to impose
so if you want to impose a break up on a
large company like Microsoft what you're
gonna do is separate its operating
system on the one hand from its various
peripheral operations on the other this
will do absolutely nothing in antitrust
firms because it turns out that the
monopoly power if you have one is in the
operating system and so long as that is
kept as a unified whole then it turns
out that the problem is going to exist
or whether or not you spin off the
application side of the business or not
and then if you try to break up the
operating system you do run into a very
serious problem under the circumstances
which is the way in which you're now
going to get the two parts to start to
interconnect with one another or there
are other problems so for example you
talk about privacy and this is a hugely
important issue and often times it's
extremely difficult
exactly who's responsible for what when
leaks start to take place and data is
taken over and so on if you have one or
two large companies with large databases
in there's a leak generally speaking is
easy to track down where it comes from
then if you have a number of small
companies who may have less effective
techniques with respect to the ways in
which these operate than the larger
companies and so that what you can do is
in an effort to try to deal with the
antitrust kinds of issues is you could
create exposures that you don't want to
welcome in other kinds of areas so when
you start to think about this question
of breaking up this is a momentous
problem generally speaking you could say
with perfect confidence as you start to
break these people up that the value of
the shares in its constituent parts is
going to be less than the whole when
it's put together at that particular
point if you're running a social
examination what you then have to do is
to figure out exactly where the social
game is coming from with respect to the
break-up and you can show that what you
can show is an effect that new people
trying to come into the industry will
have fewer people with whom they can
deal and so forth there'll be privacy
problems there'll be huge transactions
cause there may be serious
misallocations in the way in which you
allocate things from one point to
another you don't want to do it and just
the last point is when it comes to the
political markets they're particularly
vibrant today precisely because there's
so many more channels now than they were
ever before this is a case where
technology has gotten rid of the problem
of holdup has reduced the influence of
the FCC and we're all the better off of
that because again what we want to
remember is that technology can enable
just as it can restrict and so the point
is to look to those bad practices that
firms undertake and to stop them but to
stop messing around with the size of the
industry in the vain hope you can make
this thing actually work thank you
[Applause]
thanks to you both
we now go to the QA part of the evening
I as I mentioned to Tim Wu and now to
you Richard
will will be give you guys any
opportunity want to ask each other
questions at any time there's often just
an inclination to solicit the audience
of questions first so line up at the mic
since you'll be up pretty soon I I do
want to take moderators prerogative just
ask one question if Tim Wu and then and
then have Richard comment when Richard
Tim emphasized a couple of times that
the question is you you say that it's
too big but then then then what do you
do like for example what would you do
about Amazon if you would let's say to a
rule well you're too big we've got to do
some breakup we've got to do some
curbing what would you curb what would
you break up yeah I don't have any
blanket sort of rule that says you have
to do anything I think it is important
to be case by case to be sensitive I
think it would be not disruptive and
good for competition for Facebook all
right okay
[Music]
okay no button open no bones broken just
a little milk on the floor and I think
we're okay right yeah good yeah I Tim
that broke your train of thought big
time so maybe you want it they're going
to go back God you know dial it back a
little bit and start again go ahead so I
don't I don't have any you know grand
aspirations to say you know we have a
rule we break up every firm because you
do it for the joy of it I think if you
need to look carefully in every
situation and ask whether it would do
better with competition in obvious ways
and I want to give an example where I
think that's true so Facebook in my view
illegally acquired two of its most
dangerous competitors what's up an
Instagram it is a violation of the
Sherman Act to buy your competitors
because the antitrust law believes in
competition not monopoly and I think you
should ask Facebook to divest Instagram
and what's up to be separate companies
so that you then have three main social
networks competing with each other I
think there's a lot of you know contrary
to what Shep Steen said this is not
impossible this is not something that
you know destroys life for the American
you know for the average person I mean
now you have Instagram and and what's up
and Facebook competing with each other
and that is the spirit of the antitrust
laws which is we believe in competition
not in monopoly I think that those firms
facing independent pressure to protect
privacy independent pressure to provide
better protection against foreign
electoral attack independent pressure to
treat us better deliver less ads we
deliver the usual consequences of
competition over monopoly so there's an
example of a nice break up that I think
actually would do a lot to help the
American public and you know and also
deal with some of these little cons
concerns when I've talked about just
having one person with too much power
which is you know an age-old thing that
I think we want to resist so I think you
got to be careful about it I'm not
formulaic this is everything it has to
be done but I do believe that history
has shown time and time again that we
sometimes overestimate what's so great
about today's monopolist an
underestimate competition underestimate
what it means to give opportunities to a
bunch of new firms who want to give take
their take their chance in the breakup
of 18t our last big breakup everyone
said this is gonna be the worst it's
gonna destroy life as we know it out of
that fallen tree out of that carcass
came the companies that created what we
now call the internet because they offer
dial-up services companies like AOL
CompuServe and so forth and we're able
to do so free from this sort of colossal
shadow of AT&T so if you want an economy
that looks like America's I think you
should believe in controls and
ultimately breakups of illegal mergers
or anti-competitive conduct if you want
an economy look like Japan's where you
just stick with a few big monopolist and
hope that they're gonna be great and
trying to defend them and I want to just
make this clear Richard Epstein's
prescriptions our prescription for doing
nothing if you accept what he says we
continue what we've been doing for the
last 20 years which is a weakened
antitrust law which basically does
nothing except mergers like the Sprint
t-mobile merger which we just saw and we
won't soon I believe have an economy
like the Japanese economy where we don't
bother anyone we assume the companies
will do for the best but we lived in
stagnant times I come in Richard see if
I could explain that why they made two
basic points one is you want to sort of
break up the companies on the face book
in its acquisition and so forth the
first thing is when these mergers took
place there were very different
companies than they were now they were
exhaustive reviews that had been taken
under the FTC to see whether or not
these things should have got gone
forward I think they made a perfectly
defensible judgment it was Bill Co bass
kick I think who was in charge of these
things a real pro in this business and
they decided given the state of the
companies then that these things in fact
we're not going to be able to win
because they were companies that were
much smaller than now now if you want to
break them up it's an implicit transfer
in some sense from Facebook to other
companies
perhaps all the shareholders will be
just fine but then there's the next
question that starts to take place and
their twofold one is it's gonna be real
hard to get future mergers that make
sense technically if you're gonna have
this consequence coming on you
afterwards and it's also the same
problem that they had with respect to
Microsoft which is that if you have
yourself an integrated company and you
want to break these things up you're
gonna have to take thousands upon
thousands upon thousands of line of code
and try to figure out which belong to me
and which belong to thee and how it is
that you're gonna run any connection
between these companies when you start
to have it this is not anything that you
can do is something which they
eventually shied away from in a
Microsoft case even though they came up
with inferior stuff Japan is a very
different company from the United States
it is not a company which simply lets
things alone Japanese is a company which
essentially has had restricted entry
practices from beginning to end impose
by matters of law and what they've
managed to do is to take a once dynamic
economy that was gonna capture the world
in 1980 and have turned it into some
kind of an economic doormat precisely
because they're mercantilist to the core
the last thing I want to do is to give
any protection to any American company
when it comes and they start to face
competition and so I mentioned for
example the Qualcomm stuff and you get
yourself time when these companies and
start to chew away at their particular
situations you get counter-attacks
lining to go on a no sign that there's a
lack of competition the real danger is
that there will be a lack of competition
if this is gonna be taken over and run
by a judge in San Jose who does not know
what she is talking about or doing when
she starts to make these kinds of
situation and so you also have to
remember if you start talking about
various kinds of regulation on these
companies you have another monopolist
that you have to deal with it's called
Uncle Sam or some of the states and it's
not at all clear that these guys know
exactly the way in which it's going to
start to happen so if you start to look
for example at the AMEX merger which
took place it's a kind of a complicated
deal I think in effect the United States
eventually backed off the state of Ohio
decided to pursue but this is a
two-sided market and you have really
complicated two sides of markets it
turns out that unless you have subsidies
going across a platform on the market
itself turns out to be inefficient if
you look at what the government did with
respect to this and the
at card market they wrecked an industry
to very large extent because they didn't
understand the way in which this thing
started to work and so if it's amateur
hour in the FTC or amateur hour in the
DOJ or damn it around in the Congress
with the likes of Richard Durbin what
you have to do is to realize that you
can do an immense amount of damage with
the government because at this point
there's no new entry that can weaken it
so I think Japan in fact is a basket
case we have to avoid all of that and I
think what happens is the steady as you
go perfectly sensible antitrust policy
which is not pussycat and lied down is
the way to continue we don't need to
have special targets for large tech
companies because of their songs um
thank you okay question from the floor
just frame your question as a question
please you don't have to identify
yourself where does one draw the line
between the most successful most
competitive company and a monopoly well
I mean that's the exact renewal
component what you do is if you're the
most successful company because you're
the most resourceful company and you get
very launched Shaam if there's free
entry into this particular business and
you provide an efficiency justification
you don't want to mess with success but
if it turns out that the way in which
you got this was through mergers or
through Kartal is a ssin than you do and
so what you do is you figure out the way
in which it goes now what makes this
somewhat more difficult to deal with is
there is clearly a very large sentiment
particularly in Europe that when you
have a dominant platform even if it's
lawfully acquired do you want to have
various service obligations that you're
going to impose upon it and you know get
the priorities right as to where the ads
are place them things that that's what
my view is that practice restrictions
are something that you always ought to
consider but consider them carefully but
that break up which goes to the size is
almost always the wrong solution if you
got success through sighs that's Brunel
that's the Alcoa case we want not to
reverse those policies comment from Jim
yeah so I think that you know having
studied the history of large companies
monopolies I think they go through a
natural life cycle and often companies
become a successful large because they
have good products and the great end of
and people love them and that is their
early stage and that's fine the problems
and the time the government needs to get
involved is when firms get a little bit
older to become a little less interested
in trying to build new products a lot
more interested in trying to keep out
potential competitors even at their
early stages in other words they're not
unlike members of Congress who start out
talking about how great everything's
gonna be and become interested only in
keeping themselves in power and that's
the point I think where antitrust
becomes important I want to make a
really key point because he's focused on
barriers to entry which is that failure
to enforce the antitrust laws is itself
a buried entry and that's what we're
talking about here when you give firms
an idea as we have for the last 20 or 30
years that you can essentially twenty
years particularly can do whatever you
want you can build up barriers to entry
you can buy out your main competitors
there is no nothing stopping firms from
building up barriers to entry and
therefore insulating themselves from the
forces of competition which we both
believe in and you know mark my words I
will tell you that if there is no
antitrust or if we keep at the levels we
have now which are pussycat which are
weak which have allowed firms to with
impunity buy out their competitors
merged into tight oligopolies we will
face a future in the tech industries
where we talk about them and like what
happened this used to be you know the
the engine of the US economy but we
decided well they can really do no wrong
let nature take its course
well Facebook book beat myspace so you
know when there's nothing to worry about
it's like an exception to the usual laws
of of economies of scale mark my words
we will see higher prices reduce
competition reduce growth reduce
opportunity for entrepreneurs unless we
start eliminating entry barriers which
is what the antitrust my words this will
never happen if you start to look at
some of these great companies who
proposed barriers to entry you could
start thinking of companies like AOL and
that really worked out terrifically when
they had the first movement you could
look at a company like Jack Welch's GE
which he built which fell apart when in
fact that
this if you engage in sloth and spend
your time trying to deal with barriers
to entry basically what you've done is
you've signed your own death warrant one
of the constant Maxim's that people have
in competitive industries is that the
only way that you can conceive could
succeed is to cannibalize your own
products that is if you've got a
dominant product at one particular point
in time you know that it's half-life is
gonna be X years if you don't eat it up
and put in a new company somebody else
is gonna eat it up and so you're gone
either way and so the question is how do
you survive and it requires that so
these companies are constantly
innovation laboratories but it's very
difficult in many cases for larger
companies to do that because they don't
have the right incentives to get small
products into big products because it's
too small an issue for the top
management to worry about so in the
natural cycle you want small companies
to be independently owned and then when
they have a coherent product either sell
to somebody else is to go public and
there's absolutely no sign that this
cycle has stomped the number of
companies that have been built in the
last 10 or 20 years with billion dollar
valuations whose names I've never heard
of is the number of companies built in
the last five or six years with billion
dollars of I don't know who these people
are but I'm not the relevant door this
is the problem you're talking about ten
years ago no talking about today you're
talking about there's much more
innovation today than there's ever been
before the biggest mistake that you had
was not at the end you got to get out
more and talk to more venture
capitalists taking too much time you
know you got to talk to where the action
is there's the venture you talk to any
venture capitalists and they'll say like
you know yes that week say you're
talking about 10 years ago you talk
about 15 years ago maybe that you're
talking about the Golden Age of Silicon
Valley those days are over
they have gone but the new generation of
vendors campus is going up if you check
for example levels of patent innovation
which is a pretty good mark of
innovation and these things the number
of applications is way up the numbers
not weighed down I think it's just
irresponsible and inaccurate to start to
say that when you've had a constant
antitrust policy for the last 20 years
which produced the gains 10 years ago
which you said that somehow or other is
going to produce the failures the big
difference now is that the Obama
processes were always regulatory on
labor and similar kind
of issues terrible patent statute and so
forth and that was really harmful and I
think the things will start to get
better don't get rid of the antitrust
laws but by heaven's sake don't try to
create any of these fancy innovations
all of which are going to lead to real
technological stagnation hey this
question is mostly for Richard many
right-wing dissident voices such as
Nicholas J Fuentes monopolist loora
loora loora loora etc have been banned
from social media platforms and I do to
the network effect of YouTube Twitter
Facebook and whatnot I don't believe
they can reach an audience that their
left-wing counter-plan counterparts can
they can form an obscure blog or a
podcast but these are niche
comparatively now I happen to think that
you are on to something which is very
serious in these particular cases but
it's just not the Internet the same
thing happens to the federal society
when it tries to run meetings and it
finds that it's going to be picketed
it's happened to Brett Kavanaugh and he
wants Austin want the president and I
think what really has to happen in these
cases is a following kind of structural
organization you cannot on any kind of a
program if it turns out that you're a
partisan with respect to the some of the
issues so if Jack Dorsey is a left-wing
if you want to get the hell out of
Twitter and let somebody else take it
over who's politically indifferent and I
also think by the way it may not be an
antitrust solution in these cases but I
do think in fact there may be a
contractual obligation that is being
breached when these characters announces
they always do they're trying to be fair
and impartial and you're all sign and I
would certainly allow for that kind of
campaign to go I think in some of these
cases in fact the remarks that you make
about these people are downright
defamatory and while it is that you may
not be required to put them on their
network to start to say about
organizations of which I'm a part of
support that they're always fascist
operation or what they're trying to do
is to oppress this and the other group I
regard that stuff is very very serious
so there are remedies I think that need
to be had but they're gonna be in
contract law and they're gonna be in
defamation law they're not gonna be an
antitrust so I want to
turn again I'm sorry but let me just
understand what what should these people
do have been been what would you do if
Facebook and Twitter said to you Richard
get the hell off what I would do in
effect is I mean me I would basically
continue with my PI across cuz I don't
know
I would think of our a serious
institutional competitor I would sue
them for breach of the contract a fair
deal in which they announce to all their
potential customers so these people
should bring a lawsuit whooping I mean I
think I mean my view about it that would
work now the question is if you go
before judges who are completely
sympathetic with that people have made
that decision it's not gonna work
if you go before neutral judges and then
you start C Prager University getting to
problems I mean I'm quite appalled at
the fact that somebody wants to knock
them off because I agree with many of
the things that Dennis says even though
I disagree the reason that the reason
Richards sorry please there is the
Richard the reason Richards answer
didn't quite make any sense is because
he's dancing around the fact that there
is a problem of concentrated power over
speech in these areas and I don't care
what side whether you're on the right or
the left I think that you don't want a
tiny number of platform owners setting
speech codes for the United States and
they have and we have you know what's
being built right now at Facebook and
Twitter even though some of it may be
closer to my politics is one of the most
powerful sensor mischief machines ever
built in the history of humankind and if
you're on the wrong end of that it's
it's very unpleasant and you know
Richards suing Facebook for defamation
is not an answer for being thrown off
this this is the reality of private
power you know these are people who have
strong opinions and I just think it's
too much power concentrated than too few
people and that's one of the reasons
that's non-economic that's frankly
political for why we have the antitrust
laws is to try to fight against this
problem of too few too much power too
few spots but too few well too few
individuals the antitrust may get you
from three to four firms and all these
firms may have the same politics it's
not going to be a solution to this
problem and what makes it worse is if
you don't have
but guys doing this would least make the
appearance of trying to adjust thing
you're gonna have the government trying
to do all this and then you have a
single monopolist who's going to be
involved trying to figure out what's
teak coach that wants and so now you're
a new situation is to have the speech
codes that they put in place at the
University of California dominate the
way in which everything works so the
answer here is there is no first best
answer the question is which is the best
second best answer and my view about it
is I think that everybody like Tim when
a moment you start seeing somebody like
Twitter do something like that you go on
Twitter and you blast Twitter for
engaging in those kinds of activities I
regard it as very very dangerous
just the way I regard shouting down
speakers at public events as being
extraordinarily dangerous to me the real
problem is the polarization and
intolerance in American society that
puts people like that into these kinds
of positions I think it's really tragic
really tragic that every one of these
big magnets that these big tech
companies is hopelessly uninformed
left-wing in terms of their politics
question hi my name is Michael Madrid I
have a question for Tim Tim with regard
to takeover of um close competitors
you've mentioned delete Instagram and
whatsapp do you have other examples you
would point to and you have I believe
you said that enforcement should be
flexible but I imagine we would need
some sort of objective standards if so
what would you envision yes so I think
you need to draw the line at that at
mergers to monopoly or three-to-two you
know he's talking about four to threes
and stick with the line that it's not
okay to buy out your most dangerous
competitors so other examples besides
that I think for example that Google
should not have been allowed to buy ways
the other major mapping program and
doesn't make sense to me that you have
one company controlling the two major
you know ways of figuring out from A to
Z how do you get from A to B
and the reason is that those firms are
both potential platforms for new
entrants into these markets and so that
there's another example I question
whether some of Amazon's acquisitions
should have been allowed particularly of
other online retailers that where they
you know might have been another
platform to creating more competition in
this area or maybe they wouldn't be
bought out by Walmart or Target to
create a stronger competitor my overall
message is that through merger policy
and it's not just a big tech it's also
across the economy and and you know
other parts of tech like broadband and
which we've focused less on that we've
just sort of given up on the idea of
competition and I don't think you need
to be you know any kind of Raving you
know right wing left wing any person to
believe that you know competition is
much better track record than does
monopoly and that's what I this is where
I disagree profoundly with Epstein you
sort of with Richard Epstein is he sort
of naturally believes that everything
will take care of itself but I think the
track record suggests from the 19th
century onward that main these
industries become monopolies and the
monopolies actually do stick around for
a long time you know one time people
thought AT&T was the most vibrant and
exciting and innovative company in the
world the 1950s people said General
Motors is so innovative
we can't ever imagine a company like
that stagnating they just think of
something new every day but these
companies managed to one way or another
create barriers to entry and they were
undisciplined and not subject to the
forces of competition particularly AT&T
and eventually the the wunderkind of
today becomes a stagnant monopolist of
tomorrow so that's why I think you know
like I'm not that interventionist I'm
just saying you got to keep a watch on
it and stop the most aggressive obvious
mergers - monopoly mergers from 3 to 4
to 3 3 to 2 and we haven't done that
based on this sort of magic dust that we
think oh you know there's something
magical about tech you know it's it's
cyber activated and you know so it
doesn't matter I think what's happening
is we're learning that the old economic
lessons are too true for tech as well
which is that you that many of these
markets tend towards monopoly and that
monopolies in the long run are highly
inefficient everybody
these monopolies are highly inefficient
but that doesn't dictate the nature of
your merger policy there so take ways in
Google suppose you decided that ways
could not be taken over by Google
there's nothing which says that this
tiny little company from Israel would be
able to get the sufficient financial
backing to become a viable competitor
and so instead of having a more
efficient Google you have to take into
account the possibility that you're
gonna have a less efficient Google and
nobody coming in then what happens is
you put it in there and they merge with
Waze if you haven't no barriers to entry
policy it doesn't prevent anybody else
from getting a patented or trade secret
alternative technology so they could
take after the combined company you're
gonna say oh it's a little bit harder
because these guys are more efficient
than it would have otherwise it'd been
but that's to ignore the fact that the
efficient company does a lot more
service than it would have done if it
had been a less efficient company so I
just don't see it in terms of the large
companies like general well AT&T it was
protected by a statutory monopoly if you
go back and you look at the hush phone
case this monopoly was so powerful in
1956 that when somebody wanted to put a
little thing on the end of the receiver
so you could hear things better are the
antitrust it rather the FTC said all
right actually said you can't do that
because it's an end-to-end monopoly that
runs by AT&T these guys are at the end
what broke this down in effect and what
really has to be given the impression
was that MCA or MCI rather decided to
run a dedicated line from Saint Louis to
Chicago in order to transmit data they
didn't need the benefit of the network
effect that you have when you're trying
to get telephone calls and then they
sued an antitrust violation against AT&T
and which was a pretty well conceived
complaint so the issue is not whether
you want to have an antitrust law or a
merger policy and so forth but you've
got to be able to apply it correctly and
I think most of the efforts in this
particular business are going to be
misconceived
if you're trying to make sure that
little companies that may become big
companies cannot be acquired there's a
real benefit of allowing them to be
acquired which is although little
companies will come in and if you want
to get them to become public offerings
you have to change the securities law or
which have had two very bad effects it
delays the time at which companies go
public it increases the
likelihood that they'll be taken over
and it increases the likelihood that
companies that are public is gonna try
to go private so if you look at the
number of listings on the New York Stock
Exchange you want to tell me what the
answer is or should I tell you it's way
down right and it's because of a bunch
of knuckleheaded policies that have
taken place in the SEC people who are so
dumb that they don't realize that the
protection you give to a small investor
is to say buy a mutual fund instead of
wrecking in the market
the current SEC problem says we got all
these bemis on the fast track we got to
make room for the bicycles that's what
they're trying to do unforgivable
I'm glad you mentioned statutory
monopoly because I think that's an
important topic so statutory monopoly is
monopoly protected by government and one
of the I think dangers of one of the
dangers of continuing to tolerate and in
fact celebrate tech monopoly is I think
it's predictable in fact serving in
government I felt this this coming that
the major tech monopolies Facebook being
example will begin to ask in one way or
another more subtly or less subtly for
protection from competition from
government now the way facebook does
this Facebook if you haven't noticed
recently has started to ask to be
regulated now that might seem a little
weird what is Facebook want to be
regulated why do they want privacy laws
well they know that if they have
influence over privacy law they can
design a regime so complicated so
Byzantine that it gives Facebook the
advantage and makes it almost impossible
to start a company because of the
start-up costs and compliance costs with
these privacy regimes Europe's privacy
law gdpr which i don't think has been
that effective has however been very
effective as an insulation of the main
Tecmo Napoles from competition so i
think one of the problems with
tolerating monopoly is the inevitably
understand we need to protect this
monopoly the best way to protect this
monopoly is government we can do that by
group some of them do it by enormous
accumulation of patent and the other way
is just asked for some complicated
regulatory regime that keeps us in power
and makes it harder to challenge us so I
think that is the next step I think
that's one of the the challenges and to
pretend that's not going to happen would
be naive I think that too
distinctions one is amassing patents if
you get them in a sensible way to put
together a portfolio can be as people
well understood a form of vertical
integration in the 1992
antitrust guideline on this which says
that you cannot put into the same patent
pool competitors but only compliments is
in fact an appropriate response that was
done I think it was under the either the
late Bush of the early Clinton
administration and it's a perfectly good
Dale I know what Tim says about the
other thing is going to the government
to ask themselves to regulate me so as
to raise my rivals costs even greater is
the absolute kind of thing that a
classical liberal terian like myself
gags on our because what it does is it
shows the dangerous but this has
happened all the time you get
organizations like the TVA and other
kinds of places that get government
subsidies to operate and then they put
restrictions on private firms and so
that's a way of killing private
enterprise and then what you do is you
get other private firms that get the
inside track and they could then kill
upstarts coming in from without and so
the basic rule here is never never never
ever ever ever let people go to the
government so I think Tim would how do
you prevent that from happening they're
already there I was in government and
facebook says we want to be your friends
and one of the things we have to do is
take care of nor pennington one of the
worst decisions ever which essentially
says if your petition the government for
cartel like activities you get an
absolute immunity from the antitrust law
and that should not be the case that's
exactly what happened with the right
amendment which basically wrecked the
Dallas Airport market for god knows how
many years and you simply don't want
that to happen so I think no privileges
no special antitrust laws be the same
old boring stuff I think the situation
isn't emerged in the 1990s which was
kind of bipartisan has done perfectly
well and when people start to go beyond
it as with the microsoft case on the
remedial side you run into real troubles
we have to have a one more question
when you look at the areas of the tech
economy that have experienced most
dynamism in there in recent years I
would point to enterprise markets where
you've seen companies adopt Linux based
technologies like AWS
Microsoft Azure and Unleashed you know
software a service and the economy that
come as a result of that and then I
would also point to Android and the
adoption of that as a mobile operating
system and the ways in which that's
encouraged innovation and them in mobile
app space and then when you talk about
the issues that you brought up right so
for example the you know Facebook
brought up both both were you're talking
about it right you know Facebook and it
isn't really a lot of that driven by a
lack of transparency and a lack of you
know lack of lack of using open source
technologies and in that way isn't
really the solution to a lot of these
problems not antitrust but requiring or
encouraging the adoption of open source
technologies by the way as you use two
words in the dick interconnected Lee
which has never be linked together
encouraging and requiring you you can
encourage anything you darn well please
but please don't try to please both
sides yeah I mean but what this can't be
to give you about one illustration the
UNIX thing comes up and what Microsoft
says to you you're a rump amateur you
want to have the Box open and everything
done its software for dummies will
supply you because we know you're a
dummy and on the other hand people
actually put together their own network
say go to you next you get a perfectly
good segregation right as it is I send
second and nobody in my belief and and
and faith and open platforms is driving
entrepreneurial innovative conduct the
same as you said and I think the
importance of the antitrust laws is in
telling companies if they're gonna
operate an open platform that they can't
trick people they can't pretend it's
open and say well you know here's this
open platform and then and then come
along later and play with the game so it
offers a warning people running open
platforms they really have to be open
that was the offshoot the Microsoft case
I think that was one of its most
important ideas and that's why it's a
tradition I think is important because
we need to have open platform companies
understand that if they want the
benefits of promising an open platform
they really do have to keep it open
thank God Tim is a libertarian he's
basically argued for an anti fraud
proposition with
to open software okay and we now go to
the summary part of the evening I'm
afraid we'll have to cut off all the
questions I hope that both of you guys
will stick around because I because I
think that number of the people in the
audience is gonna want to chat with you
afterwards but meanwhile we want to go
to the summations so take it away check
sure five minutes thanks I'm confident
you'll be able to so I think what we
face tonight and I think it's been a
good debate is the classic question of
monopoly and the u.s. system and the US
economy and I want to suggest that we at
the United States came up with an
innovative answer a classic answer to
the problem of monopoly and that is the
antitrust laws they are a middle point I
would suggest between a full lays a fair
form of capitalism and and other central
planning socialistic answers and I think
has had an extraordinary track record
over the last century for the US economy
based on the idea the sort of basic
principle idea the competition is better
than monopoly and what I want to suggest
and I want to say that that's true both
in the in the economic side where over
the long run I think that stagnant
industries dominated by one monopolist
or two or two monopolist do underperform
competitive industries over the long
period whether it's innovation whether
it's growth on any measure I don't think
it's it's it's seriously in question but
I also think this is an important matter
when we think about the broader speech
and political consequences I think that
and I reiterated this multiple times
that there is always a danger from too
little accountability too much control
in too little few hands over speech over
data
over privacy and that those questions
are not new but they have been settled
and and and repeatedly addressed by the
idea of telling private industry that
there is a final constraint on their
power that there is some sort of form
sort of final oversight backstop beyond
which they cannot go and that is through
using illegal means to maintain a
monopoly and merging to monopoly and one
of the things I want to emphasize is
that you know so much of what Richard
Epstein wants to happen so much of this
idea of churn of new companies coming in
industry of new voices being heard is a
result of some kind of outer limit and
you may not do this and that's what I'm
talking about when I'm talking about the
revival of antitrust that's what I'm
talking about what I'm saying we can't
pretend we're living in the year 2005
and the internet is just you know a
thousand firms and and new and and
there's no competitive advantages to
anybody and platforms don't last we have
lived through an experience of
consolidation in the internet industries
they are not industries they were before
they are controlled by fewer and fewer
players and I think they have to be
watched very carefully we can't
preemptively say you know we don't care
about anything that has done in these
areas we need to be very serious about
the problem of buying out competitors of
creating barriers to entry and last what
I what I said earlier which is the the
problem of asking for statutory monopoly
and asking for special government
protection against competition that's
the direction where I'm concerned that
we're going to see that the future go so
if I end this I would return to where I
began and say we've had a successful
track record in America in challenging
our most successful challenging our
dominant firms and has taken the United
States to preeminence to leadership in
the tech industry now is not the time to
say the tech industry should can do no
wrong now is not the time to say that
we're going to allow any and bless any
merger
because we think there's something
special about big tech I think it's time
for scrutiny I think it's time to make
it understood that there is some kind of
final backstop and I think that policy
and that policy alone is the kind of
thing that will maintain the vibrancy of
the US economy and also preserve the
conditions of democracy which seem under
greater threat than ever so thank you
very much I appreciate your time
[Applause]
let's sort of start from the beginning
about what it is that we do with the
problem of monopolies and how we deal
with it I mean the first point to
understand is an antitrust is not the
only tool that has to work for that arm
is also vods history of regulated
industries which actually started the
same year as the passage of the Sherman
Act 1890 with the Minnesota rate cases
because there's some monopolies that you
can't break up so rate regulation some
other form of regulation is appropriate
that system of regulation generally
doesn't work so much for the internet
situation because they don't charge
prices like you do for electricity for
gasoline and so what you can't do is to
sort of try and control the rates when
the rates turn out to be zero
you could try to alter other things in
the mix that are going to take place but
generally speaking if you tell people
for example that you're not gonna get
advertisement and you have to pay for
things that's gonna probably be far more
disastrous than anything else when it
comes to the antitrust laws we've had a
very erratic situation even when you go
back to the age of big business and the
way in which these things work a
Northern Pacific survives they go after
Standard Oil and they manage to do so
just after it's lost its monopoly power
in that particular industry
point which is debated but you give a
very large industry and you got a lot of
moving technologies other people are
going to come in are the antitrust laws
through basically the late 1940s through
the mid 1970s was generally a very bad
body of law some of the mergers stuff in
cases like bonds grocery and so forth a
brown shoe were the sorts of things that
happened where you prevented very small
companies from merges
and it was only when we had the
discipline of using the her friend
dollar index to measure but the
concentration ratios ought to be that we
brought that to some degree of a
situation and so what Tim says is surely
true that we prefer competition to
monopoly and nothing I've ever said I
would ever want to deny that it is also
surely true that we never want to let
anybody whether a competitor or a
monopolist go to the government and get
some kind of special favor a
dispensation which puts differential
costs on their competitors
that's just essentially an abuse of the
public process and we need to take steps
to make sure that government doesn't
have that kind of discretion which is
one of the reasons why I've argued very
strongly for a strong takings clause in
the Constitution to prevent that kind of
government discretion from moving
resources from one party to another it
is in fact a self conscious effort to
try to room it rent-seeking that takes
place and you can only do that at the
government level you should expect all
private firms good better and different
to want to engage in behavior that will
benefit themselves whether they do so in
ways that benefit their social welfare
or whether they do so in ways that are
antithetical to that social welfare and
that's a reality but when you want to
try to apply these particular positions
you really have to be very very careful
you have to know who is a monopoly and
you have to know whether a particular
merchant it turns out to be something
that is anticompetitive you have to
worry about whether or not it's the
dominant player whom you're stopping or
whether it's something else if you will
look at the history of the antitrust
laws or what you discover is it divides
itself into three categories category
number one is per se offenses where
except in narrow circumstances you think
that the consequences are likely to be
bad and the rules with respect the
chordal is a ssin and the collective
refusal to deal are things that actually
make that an antitrust does it the
merger law is very very much more
difficult so if you go back to Ollie
Williams since classical paper on this
he gives you a little diagram and he
shows that when the merger starts to
take place it's got some restrictive
power on the one hand then it has some
efficiencies on the other and you have
to figure out which of these two forces
turns out to be dominant and that
requires a kind of an Inquirer that you
cannot do in court and so you have to do
to have some administrative body do that
we had that all the way through this
particular period Tim may disappear with
the results that happened there but the
people who made these judgments
certainly had the right criterion I
think in many particular cases what they
did is they came up with the right
result and then third you always have to
worry about cases of predation and I
think those are extremely dangerous
cases to be because to the extent that
you call something predation which
drives out somebody else you may well be
confusing an efficient victor within a
you evil Victor and what happens is
you're proposing anti-competitive
strategies through the antitrust law and
so the basic lesson that you have to
learn is that the antitrust laws like
every other tool that we have in
government sometimes it works for good
sometimes it works for bad what you
really need to do is to figure out a
filter which way and which is going to
go as I've tried to indicate a stopping
the various kinds of efficient
inefficient merges stopping abuses of
government power stopping private
mechanisms that engage in force a fraud
or all part of what we need but breaking
up big tech is not thank you and it
looks as though we are getting the
results that Jane is handing me and so I
will read the results okay
again antitrust should take the
initiative to control size of big tech
companies the yes vote initially got
27.2% and picked up votes to thirty
point one that's a two point nine
percent gain for the yes vote that's the
number to beat
the no vote got forty three percent went
to 61% a 17 percent dank gain so the no
vote gets the Tootsie Roll
congratulations
you